bonjour à tous merci de nous rejoindre
en direct du Sénat pour la séance des
questions d'actualité au Gouvernement
une séance qui va être marquée par la
réforme du collège puisque pas moins de
5 questions sur dix cet après-midi vont
être adressés à la ministre de
l'Éducation nationale qui a annulé un
déplacement cet après-midi pour venir
répondre au sénateur on va suivre cette
séance en direct à partir de 15h sur
notre antenne mais avant notre invité
c'est Bernard Cazeneuve le ministre de
l'Intérieur bonjour merci d'être avec
nous en directe sur ce plateau en ce
moment même se tient au Sénat une
conférence de presse sur votre projet de
loi renseignement le Sénat souhaite
amender de façon assez significative ce
projet de loi pas moins de 145
amendements ont été déposés des
sénateurs qui veulent introduire des
garde-fous je dirais plutôt technique
pour le respect de la légalité dans
l'activité de renseignements ils veulent
par exemple des sanctions pénales pour
les agents qui sortent du cadre légal
j'imagine que là vous serez d'accord
nous allons examiner tous ces
amendements bien sûr il va également
ramener les autorisations d'écoute de 4
mois à deux mois est-ce que là vous
allez être ouvert au dialogue sur ce
point nous n'allons pas faire le débat
sur votre plateau avant qu'il ne se
déroule en séance nous avons beaucoup
travaillé avec la commission des Lois du
Sénat dans un esprit constructif
pourquoi d'abord parce que nous
souhaitons que ce texte sorte meilleur
du Sénat qu'il n'y est rentré comme nous
avons souhaité qu'il sorte meilleur de
l'Assemblée nationale qu'il y était
rentré c'est sur ces questions une
nécessité que de laisser le débat
parlementaire se déployer qu'est-ce que
nous voulons nous voulons encadrer
l'activité des services de renseignement
c'est la raison pour laquelle au
lendemain de l'affaire Snowden Jean-Marc
Hérault avait demandé à l'époque à deux
parlementaires d'élaborer un projet de
loi et nous voulons des services de
renseignement qui soient contrôlés par
des structures qui fassent un contrôle
réel qu'il s'agisse de l'autorité
administrative de l'indépendant qui
verra ses pouvoirs conforter par rapport
à la SNCS qu'il s'agisse du contrôle
juridictionnel considérablement renforcé
qu'il n'existait pas et qui désormais
de façon puissante exercée par le
Conseil d'État et la délégation
parlementaire au enseignement qui a un
véritable pouvoir de contrôle de
l'activité de service de renseignement
que elle n'avait pas entre 2007 et 2012
donc des contrôles accrus 2 des
techniques centrées sur la lutte contre
le terrorisme pour les techniques dont
on a le plus parlé c'est-à-dire la
détection sur données anonyme le suivi
en temps réel des terroristes c'est
important pour prévenir la commission
d'acte terroristes et troisièmement ce
que nous voulons c'est que tout cela se
fasse dans le respect rigoureux des
principes de droit constitutionnels et
des principes généraux du droit voilà
quelle est la doctrine du gouvernement
et par conséquent tous les amendements
du Sénat comme vous le vouliez également
à l'Assemblée nationale ça veut dire
qu'il y a encore des améliorations
possibles alors selon vous et lesquelles
mais le gouvernement le gouvernement
lui-même présentera des amendements il
présentera des amendements parce que
nous sommes à l'écoute de ce que
souhaite le Parlement et nous sommes à
l'écoute aussi de
exprimé à certains nombre d'acteurs de
la société civile donc sur quel point
nous allons prendre des amendements nous
allons prendre des amendements par
exemple pour vraiment préciser que les
techniques qui ont fait le plus débats
sont des techniques de ciblage et non
pas de surveillance massive
contrairement à ce que j'ai entendu
depuis des semaines ça ne correspond pas
à la réalité et pour donner toute
garantie sur ce point nous allons
prendre des amendements qui montrent
bien que les principales activités sont
centrées sur la lutte antiterroriste de
manière à ce que le contrôle soit
effectif nous accepterons des
amendements qui conforteront encore le
contrôle de manière à donner toute
garantie sur la durée de conservation
des amendements sont présentés nous
allons les amener de manière à conforter
la constitutionnellement le texte ce que
nous voulons encore une fois à travers
ce texte c'est que l'activité des
services de renseignement soit encadrés
c'est une nécessité que les moyens
nouveaux qui leur sont donnés soient
ciblés et que les principes généraux du
loi soient respectés c'est assez simple
voilà à partir de quelle grille de
lecture
de 1991 et je pense que sur ce sujet là
il faut être à la fois dans la volonté
du contrôle et je partage tout à fait la
vie de la présidence de la CNIL et en
même temps dans la responsabilité
le monde je sais que vous voulez pas
arriver sur sur ces informations mais le
monde sort des informations autour de
d'achat curieux des doigts nous estimés
qu'il y a une opération un peu
déstabilisation justement sur
aujourd'hui les services mais moi je
n'ai pas lu cette article dont vous
permettrait de ne pas le commenter et
moi je ne commande que des documents
auxquels j'ai eu accès que je connais et
par ailleurs il n'a pas échappé à votre
sagacité que je ne suis pas le ministre
des douanes et par conséquent pas de
confirmer les informations mais est-ce
que vous avez l'impression que ces
informations tombent de façon moi je ne
peux pas comporter des informations que
je n'ai pas lu donc je vous le redis en
pleine discussion autour de votre projet
de loi mais le projet de loi que nous
discutons est un projet de loi qui
encore une fois est destiné à encadrer
les services de renseignement à mieux
lutter contre le favorise dans le
respect des libertés publiques et des
principes du droit et ça le débat
parlementaire au Sénat le montrera et je
serai comme je l'ai été depuis le début
de ce débat extrêmement rigoureux
extrêmement précis dans les réponses que
j'apporte et voyez par exemple la
Commission nationale consultative des
droits de l'homme a mis un avis sur ce
texte qui émettait énormément de
critique j'ai pris le soin de répondre
point par point à chacune des
inquiétudes parce que ce débat mérite
mieux que des approximations des
amalgames ou des emportements
médiatiques il méritent la plus grande
rigueur intellectuelle la plus grande
précision juridique j'estime que ces
deux mon rôle d'être dans cette dans ce
positionnement par rapport au texte là
où il y a beaucoup d'approximations
d'amolgame d'imprécision de
positionnement merci beaucoup Bernard
on diffusera effectivement en longueur
ces discussions autour de ce projet
loire-enseignement sur l'antenne de
Public Sénat à partir de leur permettre
d'avoir accès au débat à partir du 2
juin sur notre rentable merci je vous
laisse regagner les muscles du sauna
puisqu'on a entendu la sonnerie de la
séance de ces questions d'actualité
retentir et cette séance va débuter
d'ici quelques instants je vous rappelle
que par moins de 5 questions sur dix
aujourd'hui sont consacrés à la réforme
du collège et c'est la ministre de
l'Éducation qui va défendre sa position
Najat Vallaud-Belkacem qu'on voit sur
ces images lors de son arrivée il y a
quelques minutes au Sénat a tenu annuler
un déplacement pour venir répondre au
sénateur voilà la séance des questions
d'actualité des marques je vous laisse
la suivre et puis on se retrouve ensuite
avec nos invités ici au gouvernement je
vous rappelle que la séance est
retransmise en direct sur France 3 et
Public Sénat
la parole est à Madame Daniel Michel
pour le groupe socialiste
madame la ministre Christian Jacob
réclamait mardi un débat à l'Assemblée
sur la réforme du collège dénonçant un
véritable mépris du Parlement mais qui
méprise qui faut-il vous rappeler qu'en
2013 une loi a été votée qu'elle
s'intitulait la refondation de l'école
qu'elle a été largement débattue et
amendée ici même au Sénat oui quel
mépris de votre part que de considérer
ce travail de qualité inexistant
la réforme du collège poursuit en effet
les objectifs fixés par le législateur
dans la loi de refondation elle-même
fruit d'une longue consultation il y a
depuis deux ans la mise en oeuvre
difficile mais indispensable d'une école
à la fois plus juste et efficace cette
réforme est une nouvelle étape
il n'est plus un jour sans que Nicolas
Sarkozy ne demande l'abrogation d'une
loi ou d'un décret après le mariage pour
tous il annonce vouloir supprimer le
collège pour tous quel programme
mépris du Parlement disiez vous
reconnaissant qu'en termes de
suppression vous avez acquis durant vos
dix années au pouvoir une certaine
expérience
suppression de la tresse colorisation
suppression de trois heures
d'enseignement par semaine en primaire
soit l'équivalent d'une année de classe
sur la scolarité de l'enfant
une année
suppression de 80000 postes dans
l'Éducation nationale suppression de la
formation pratique des professeurs
suppression de 200 000 postes
supplémentaires voulu par Nicolas
Sarkozy
et
vous parlez de nivellement vers le bas
de tentatives de destruction du génie
français un peu de retenue serait la
bienvenue
Bruno Le Maire proposait en début de
semaine de sortir du Bourdieu de retirer
le social du débat sur l'école au regard
de l'aggravation des inégalités sociales
mais aussi scolaires dans notre pays je
crois à l'inverse qu'il est urgent de
s'attaquer aux mécanisme de reproduction
sociale extrêmement fort en France ce
texte y contribue en portant une idée de
l'excellence autrement plus ambitieuse
que celle qui a prévalu ces dernières
années le droit à l'excellence pour tous
et non réservé à quelques-uns
pourriez-vous Madame le Ministre
rappelez les mesures annoncées en
soutien à cet objectif merci ma chère
collègue
la parade est à Madame Najat
Vallaud-Belkacem ministre de l'Éducation
nationale de l'Enseignement supérieur et
de la Recherche merci monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs madame la sénatrice Michel
merci pour votre question
elle m'offre l'occasion de remettre en
perspective ce que fait ce gouvernement
depuis maintenant 2012 en matière de
redressement éducatif nous l'avions dit
en arrivant aux responsabilités la
France a besoin de redressement dans
tous les secteurs celui de l'éducation
nationale tout particulièrement c'est
vrai que nous sortions d'une période 10
ans 10 ans d'exercices des
responsabilités par la précédente
majorité qui avait conduit en effet
étrangement aussi bien à la suppression
de 80000 postes dans l'Éducation
nationale qu'à la suppression de la
formation initiale des enseignants alors
même que dans cette même période le
niveau des élèves n'avait cessé de se
dégrader que ce soit à l'école primaire
ou que ce soit au collège alors depuis
2012 nous avons engagé une ambitieuse
refondation de nous l'avons prise
d’ailleurs de façon très pragmatique et
très chronologique puisque dans un
premier temps c'est à l'école primaire
que nous avons voulu rétablir à la fois
plus de mètres que de classe une presse
scolarisation des enfants avant l'âge de
3 ans une meilleure formation des
enseignants face à leurs élèves et puis
est venu le temps aujourd'hui de
procéder à la réforme du collège qui
était en effet annoncé par la loi de
refondation de l'école discuter au
Parlement il y a deux ans adopté au
Parlement il y a deux ans en quoi
consiste cette réforme du collège
permettre à tous les collégiens de mieux
apprendre par une rénovation des
pratiques pédagogiques qui sont
utilisées par les enseignants rénovation
des pratiques pédagogiques qui passent
d'abord par plus d'autonomie laisser aux
établissements chefs d'établissements et
équipes pédagogique pour mieux s'adapter
aux besoins de leurs élèves qui ne sont
pas exactement les mêmes d'un territoire
à l'autre d'un établissement à l'autre
permettre aux équipes pédagogiques de
mettre le paquet pardonnez-moi pour
l'expression sur le français il y a des
lacunes évidentes sur les maths quand il
y en a d'autres ailleurs c'est une
nécessité indispensable cette réforme du
collège elle prévoit aussi de moderniser
les apprentissages pour renforcer les
compétences de nos élèves les élèves qui
entreront sur le marché du travail en
2025 par exemple devront maîtriser mieux
les langues vivantes étrangères
maîtriser mieux le numérique ce sont des
choses qui sont prévues dans cette
réforme du collège mieux s'exprimer à
l'oral apprendre à travailler en groupe
faire preuve de créativité c'est ce
qu'il est attendu dans un monde moderne
où les métiers à haute valeur ajoutée
seront ceux qui devront trouver preneur
voilà ce que cette réforme du collège
prévoit et c'est la raison pour laquelle
je vous remercie pour votre soutien
merci Madame la Ministre la parole est à
Monsieur Jean-Marie bauquel pour le
groupe Union des démocrates et
indépendants merci monsieur le Président
Madame la Ministre votre réforme du
collège suscite une vie vos positions et
pour cause outre le contenu de la
réforme c'est d'abord la méthode
employés qui s'apparente à une
provocation
par la publication hier au Journal
Officiel du décret d'application sans
consultation préalable du Parlement sans
concertation de la communauté éducative
et qui plus est au lendemain d'une
journée de mobilisation des enseignants
le gouvernement s'est tout bonnement
moqué du processus démocratique dans
notre pays
certes certes le Parlement a voté le
principe de votre réforme au travers de
la loi pour la refondation de l'école de
2013 mais madame la ministre cette loi
n'avait pas été accompagnée de l'annonce
d'un tel décret comme il en est pourtant
la règle vous comprendrez ainsi le
sentiment de la majorité de mes
collègues ici présent d'avoir été dupé
par votre réforme pourquoi refuser
pourquoi refuser un débat devant le
Parlement sur un sujet au cœur des
préoccupations de nos concitoyens vous
connaissez pourtant le rôle majeur de
nos commissions spécialisées à l'instar
de la commission de la culture de
l'éducation et de la communication
présidé par notre collègue Catherine
Morin de saillie très impliqué sur ce
dossier l'école française ne va pas bien
alors oui les réformes sont nécessaires
oui il faut redresser l'école mais pas
de cette manière avec cette réforme vous
tournez le dos à l'excellence
républicaine en effet donner une chance
aux élèves de viser l'excellence ce
n'est pas de l'élitisme ou alors c'est
l'élitisme républicain dont on parle
aussi bien ni une légitimation des
inégalités contrairement à ce que vous
avez récemment déclaré c'est au
contraire donner aux jeunes les moyens
de leurs ambitions c'est pourquoi madame
la ministre le sacrifice des classes
bilangues et européennes classes qui ont
permis entre autres à l'Allemand de
rester la troisième langue vivant dans
saignée en France l'atteinte portée à
l'enseignement du latin et du grec
l'affaiblissement de l'enseignement de
l'histoire
l'incompréhensible introduction des
enseignements pratiques
interdisciplinaires tout cela ne
convainc pas bien au contraire ces
mesures vont aggraver les problèmes que
nous connaissons déjà dans nos collèges
aussi pour reprendre votre expression
madame la ministre quelle garantit je
vous cite comptez vous introduire dans
les textes d'application pour répondre
au mécontentement général pas seulement
ici général et aux inquiétudes le geste
d'autorité dont le gouvernement a fait
preuve en publiant en toute a tiers le
décret d'application ne rassure pas ceux
qui sont inquiets bien au contraire
merci mon cher collègue la parole est à
madame la ministre de l'Éducation
nationale de l'Enseignement supérieur et
de la Recherche merci monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs monsieur le sénateur bokel
merci pour votre question qui me donne
l'occasion de répondre ici à quelques
procès d'intention qui nous sont
régulièrement faits nul n'est plus
attaché que moi à l'excellence mais
l'égalité n'est pas l'ennemi de
l'excellence l'égalité au contraire et
ce qui permet à chaque enfant de France
de pouvoir un jour accéder à la réussite
à chaque enfant de France de faire
valoir son mérite son travail son effort
pour pouvoir progresser ceux contre quoi
je m'élève absolument c'est en effet le
rétrécissement de cette élite dont vous
parlez le rétrécissement qu'on a cessé
de constater ces 10 dernières années
est-ce que vous allez me démentir
lorsque je vous renverrai vers la
composition sociale par exemple des
classes préparatoires ou des grandes
écoles est-ce que vous allez me démentir
quand je vous dirais que seuls 75% des
enfants d'ouvriers obtiennent le brevet
à la fin du collège quand ils sont 95 5%
parmi les enfants de cadre c'est une
réalité alors il nous faut nous y
attaquer comment est-ce qu'on s'attaque
à cette réalité des inégalités et du
déterminisme social qui est la marque de
fabrique malheureusement de notre
système éducatif français on s'y attaque
en faisant en sorte que chaque enfant
jusqu'à l'âge de 16 ans soit assuré de
pouvoir acquérir un bagage commun le
fameux socle commun de connaissance de
compétences et de culture qu'on ne
laisse pas un enfant sortir du collège
sans maîtriser les fondamentaux de
français de matou d'histoire c'est
exactement ce que prévoit cette réforme
cette réforme c'est la réforme d'une
ambition le collège unique en effet
parce qu'il faut que toute une classe
d'âge soit formée avec la même qualité
mais en même temps du refus de
l'uniformité de la personnalisation de
la pédagogie pour permettre à chaque
enfant de faire valoir son potentiel et
ses talents cette personnalisation elle
passe par l'accompagnement individuel
que nous instaurons désormais comme une
règle tous les collégiens en classe de 6
auront dans leur semaine trois heures
pendant lesquelles on les fera
retravailler les fondamentaux
approfondir pour ceux qui sont en avance
rattraper leur retard pour ceux qui sont
en difficulté un collège de 500 élèves
prenez un collège de 500 élèves
aujourd'hui il n'a que 10 heures de
dotation globale pour faire du travail
en petits groupes grâce à la réforme en
2016 il en aura 60 heures ça veut dire
qu'il aura plus de moyens pour faire
travailler les élèves en petits groupes
ça veut dire qu'on les met en meilleure
condition de réussite expliquez-moi en
quoi mettre en meilleure condition de
réussite le plus grand nombre va nuire à
ceux qui aujourd'hui sont dans la
réussite au contraire on le dit souvent
plus que le niveau de l'eau s'élève et
plus tous les bateaux monte et bien
cette réforme elle va dans l'intérêt
aussi bien des élèves en difficulté que
des élèves qui sont en réussite merci
madame la ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Gérard Longuet
pour le groupe Union pour un mouvement
populaire
oui merci monsieur le Président ma
question s'adressait à Monsieur Valls
Premier ministre pourquoi parce qu'à cet
instant la question n'est pas technique
madame le ministre nous avons écouté vos
réponses avec intérêt et nous sommes
frustrés d'un véritable débat tout ce
que vous avez dit est intéressant rien
n'est certain et il y a de véritables
erreurs ce la question qui se pose
aujourd'hui et que nous posons au
Premier ministre nous le groupe UMP
c'est la question de la façon de
conduire le changement dans ce pays et
le respect que l'on doit apporter au
véritables partenaires de ce changement
il se trouve Madame le Ministre que les
enfants n'appartiennent pas aux
théoriciens du Conseil supérieur de
pédagogique ils appartiennent à leur
famille ils sont sous la charge des
enseignants et ils sont sur la
responsabilité des chefs d'établissement
aura cet instant vous le Premier
ministre sera un décret et vous n'avez
d'ailleurs même pas signé l'arrêté vous
l'avez délégué à votre directrice mais
c'est normal c'est l'administration
c'est un texte qui est malnet il est né
d'abord d'un délit qui a fait rire parce
qu'il était prétentieux abscons et
parfois grotesque je n'y reviens pas
c'est un décret ensuite qui est
parfaitement proclammatoire péremptoire
le collège unique nous le connaissons
c'est notre compatriote lorrain René
Abby de cette formation qui a voulu le
collège unique et il a eu du mal le
collège unique a évolué le collège
unique doit se diversifier parce que les
problèmes français ont changé mais ce
changement madame vous ne l'avez pas
écrit dans la loi de 2013 et ce
changement réclame un véritable débat
parce que c'est bien plus qu'une affaire
administrative avec des pédagogues
professionnels qui depuis 40 ans n'ont
apporté aucune solution à la dégradation
de notre enseignement
et c'est la raison pour laquelle sur ce
texte malné péremptoire contradictoire
avec vos propres intentions il n'y a
rien sur l'apprentissage il n'y a rien
sur le rôle des collectivités locales
alors que l'on va demander aux
collectivités locales et aux élus de
prendre en charge les collèges les
lycées le primaire de sentir l'action
pédagogique vous ne leur faites
strictement aucune place ce texte est
malnet vous l'avez bâclé je pense
profondément je conduirai sur ce point
qu'au lendemain au lendemain faut
conclure au lendemain du 11 janvier nous
pouvions attendre que comme nous l'avons
fait sur le terrain de la Défense le
gouvernement sur le terrain de
l'enseignement élève le débat et fasse
confiance à toute la représentation
nationale quelles sont vos intentions en
la matière
la réponse est à madame la ministre de
l'Éducation nationale de l'Enseignement
supérieur et de la recherche vous avez
la parole madame la ministre merci
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Longuet je vais commencer à
nouveau par bien dissocier de sujets qui
sont différents la réforme du collège
d'un côté qui porte sur l'organisation
du collège et les pratiques pédagogiques
et la réforme des programmes de l'autre
qui a été vous le savez par la loi par
la loi confié d'abord à une instance
indépendante qui s'appelle le Conseil
supérieur des programmes pour qu'il
puisse présenter des projets de
programme qui sont aujourd'hui en
consultation auprès des 800 000
enseignants qui auront à les appliquer
cette consultation dure un mois
évidemment qu'elle amènera retravailler
la formulation des programmes c'est son
objet et je serai amené à valider
définitivement ces programmes au mois de
septembre prochain donc je vous propose
de laisser ce sujet de côté tout en
précisant cela étant que ces programmes
en vocation et c'est le cahier des
charges qui a été le mien à être plus
lisible plus progressif plus cohérent
dans la scolarité pour faire là encore
mieux réussir les élèves et leur faire
acquérir absolument les fondamentaux
dont ils ont besoin pour se projeter
dans la vie mais je reviens à la réforme
du collège vous nous parlez de la
méthode mais monsieur le sénateur enfin
la meilleure méthode qui soit pour
préparer un texte vous en conviendrez
c'est bien d'en discuter au Parlement ce
fut le cas de la loi de refondation dont
je vous rappelle que les débats ont duré
très exactement 5 mois entre l'Assemblée
nationale et le Sénat je ne sais pas si
vous y avez assisté mais dans cette loi
de refondation il était prévu que le
collège soit réformé pour y introduire
plus d'autonomie je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure de l'interdisciplinarité pour
que les élèves apprennent autrement et
s'approprie les savoirs que qui leur
sont transmis et puis l'accompagnement
personnalisé que j'évoquais à l'instant
alors vous nous dites que dans ce
nouveau collège on ne trouve plus trace
de notre attachement au développement
des relations entre les ét franchement
scolaire les collectivités locales ou le
monde professionnel c'est faux c'est
faux et si vous aviez pris le temps mais
je vous invite de regarder précisément
les textes vous verriez que par exemple
dans les fameuses d'enseignements
pratiques interdisciplinaires que nous
créons il y en est un qui est consacré
au monde professionnel quel est sa
vocation précisément apprendre au
collégien assez tôt à s'orienter pour
trouver sa voie et permettre aux
établissements scolaires grâce à
l'autonomie qu'on leur laisse de nouer
des partenariats avec les entreprises
qui les entourent avec leur
environnement de façon adaptée pour
ouvrir les horizons des élèves donc vous
voyez bien que ce soit sur la question
je l'évoquais tout à l'heure du
numérique de l'éducation artistique et
culturelle ou encore de la découverte du
monde professionnel le nouveau collège
est au contraire un collège ouvert sur
son monde et qui multiplie les chances
de réussite des élèves
la parole est à Monsieur Jean-Claude
Roquier pour le groupe de Rassemblement
démocratique et social européen merci
monsieur le Président ma question ne
s'adressera pas de la mamie sur
l'éducation nationale qui aura ainsi un
peu de répit mais à monsieur le ministre
de l'Intérieur
mes chers amis de l'intérieur la
Méditerranée est actuellement le théâtre
d'une tragédie humaine comme elle a
rarement connue dans sa longue histoire
on estime à 1700 le nombre migrants qui
ont perdu la vie depuis le début de
cette année en essayant d'atteindre les
côtes européennes tout le monde est-il
anime pour dire qu'il faut agir et que
la réponse ne peut être coréenne
c'est-à-dire coordonnées par tous les
pays de l'Union car ce n'est pas
seulement le problème de l'Italie de
l'Espagne et de la Grèce la semaine
dernière la Commission européenne a
proposé un plan d'action pour
l'immigration et l'asile dans la mesure
essentielle n'est pas passé inaperçue
puisqu'il s'agit d'instaurer des quotas
par pays d'accueil mais quel est donc
cette Europe qui répond à des drames
humains par des quotas est-ce génial
technocrate qui a une idée d'inventer
des quotas d’immigrés comme un autre
avant lui mieux respirer il est vrai
inventer des quotas laitiers pour la
commission la répartition entre les pays
de l'Union pourrait se faire en fonction
de leur richesse de la population de
leur taux de chômage et du nombre de
personnes déjà accueillies bien
évidemment les migrants dit économiques
ne sont pas concernés puis il s'agit
d'une migration irrégulière et qu'à la
matière la règle doit demeurer la
reconduite reste donc le droit d'asile
sur lequel le Sénat a travaillé ces
derniers jours il s'est accordé sur le
fondement de critères ou bien un report
ces critères et en bénéficié du statut
de réfugiés ou bien on doit quitter le
territoire on voit donc mal comment
pourrait on pourrait prévoir des quotas
le président de la République a fait
savoir que la phrase était opposée par
principe à toute idée de quota en
matière d'immigration
si vous voulez pas possible d'accepter
une répartition contraignante des
rescapés de la Méditerranée le
gouvernement se dit toutefois je le cite
pleinement favorable à ce que ces
personnes ayant un besoin manifeste de
protection puisse être de manière
temporaire et selon des paramètres à
discuter répartis plus équitablement
entre les États membres alors Monsieur
le Ministre ma question est simple
pouvez-vous éclairer le Sénat sur cette
notion de répartition solidaire et
équitable merci mon cher collègue la
parole est à Monsieur Bernard Cazeneuve
ministre de l'Intérieur sur le sénateur
vous appelez à la précision sur ce sujet
qui effectivement nécessite la plus
grande rigueur dans son approche car il
s'agit d'un sujet grave qui ne peut
trouver une réponse qu'à travers une
action forte de l'Union européenne et
une mobilisation forte des états de
l'union de quoi s'agit-il il y a d'abord
des drames humains en Méditerranée qui
résulte du fait que
des filières de la traite des êtres
humains se sont organisés pour mettre
des migrants de plus en plus vulnérables
de plus en plus nombreux sur des
embarcations de plus en plus frêles les
condamnants à la mort certaine ces
filières de la traite des êtres humains
doivent être démantelés et ceux qui les
organisent sévèrement punis par la
justice donc la première chose que nous
avons à faire c'est d'organiser un
certain nombre d'actions permettant cela
comment le faire d'abord avec les pays
de provenance parce que 70% de ceux qui
arrivent à lombet douza transitent par
la bande sahélienne et relève de
l'immigration économique irrégulière
nous devons aider ces pays à contrôler
leurs frontières c'est ce que j'ai
proposé à l'occasion de la réunion des
mises à l'intérieur du G5 Sahel en
proposant des coopérations entre nos
services et les leurs pour assurer ce
contrôle deuxièmement nous devons faire
travailler nos services de justice et de
police ensemble pour procéder au
démantèlement de ces filières nous le
faisons en France en lien avec les
services britanniques l'an dernier c'est
236 filières supplémentaires de
l'immigration irrégulière qui ont été
démantelés dont 30% de plus à Calais
deuxièmement nous devons sauver des vies
l'opération Frontex qui se substitue à
l'opération Marino Strom est une
opération de contrôle des frontières
extérieures de l'Union européenne elle
doit pouvoir sauver des vies dans le
respect du droit de la mer troisièmement
il y a deux catégories de migrants il y
a les migrants qui relèvent de l'asile
en Europe ceux qui ont vocation avoir le
statut de réfugiés en Europe
c'est-à-dire l'asile doivent être
accueillies sur la base de critères et
répartis équitablement entre les pays de
l'Union européenne la notion de quota
pour les réfugiés n'a pas de sens elle
signifierait qu'au-delà d'un plafond
l'Europe refuse d'accueillir ceux qui
ont vocation être accueillis à son sein
en son sein ce serait le contraire de la
tradition républicaine et de la vocation
de l'Union européenne au regard de ce
que sont ces valeurs et par ailleurs ce
concept de Kota n'a pas de sens pour les
migrants qui relèvent de l'immigration
irrégulière parce que eux n'ont pas
vocation à être accueillis en Europe ils
ont vocation à être reconduits à la
frontière et à faire l'objet de
politique de maintien dans leur pays et
de co-développement associant les pays
de la bande saelo saharienne voilà
quelle est la politique de la France
elle est claire et elle a inspiré la
politique de l'Union merci
la parole est à madame Aline Archambault
pour le groupe écologiste monsieur le
Président ma question s'adresse à
Monsieur le Premier ministre monsieur le
Premier ministre le drame de l'amiante
aura fait selon la direction générale de
la santé qui s'appuie sur les travaux de
l'Institut national de veille sanitaire
au moins 100000 morts en d'ici 2050 je
vous adresse cette question qui est une
question de santé publique de la plus
grande gravité mais qui concerne
également la plupart des ministères du
gouvernement comme vous le savez la
commission des affaires sociales a créé
en février 2013 au Sénat un comité de
suivi qui a travaillé sur cette question
de l'amiante du désamiantage et qui vous
a rendu en juillet 2014 il y a presque
un an ses conclusions les propositions
faites par le comité ont été
complètement consensuelles parmi les
groupes politiques au Sénat nous avons
demandé notamment la mise en place d'une
structure de coordination
interministérielle rattachée au Premier
ministre nous alertons régulièrement sur
les dangers que représente aujourd'hui
l'absence d'une strat nationale du
désamiantage pilotée par vos services
associant tous les ministères concernés
et ils sont nombreux les médecins nous
alertent déjà sur le risque d'une
deuxième épidémie qui s'ajouterait à
celle que nous connaissons si le
désamiantage n'est pas fortement piloté
par les pouvoirs publics il est urgent
que soit mis en place des priorités
nationales amélioration de la
réalisation des diagnostics amiantes
gros points faibles aujourd'hui
financement pérenne échéancier fléchage
des crédits vers la recherche
développement sur les sujets du
diagnostic des techniques de
désamiantage du traitement des déchets
développement d'une formation initiale
et continue de tous les acteurs
concernés il est possible de créer une
filière économique du désamiantage à
l'échelle nationale sans doute pour
plusieurs décennies qui seraient par
ailleurs pourvoyeuse d'emploi l'objectif
ici n'est pas de faire peur mais
d'affronter le problème lucidement en
mettant d'ailleurs aussi en place un
dispositif informations du grand public
Monsieur le Premier Ministre dis-moi
après la publication ne se rapporte
aucune nouvelle du Gouvernement sur ce
sujet les représentants du comité ont
été reçus auprès de votre cabinet fin
octobre pour lui présenter le rapport
nous n'avons pas de réaction à ce jour
on me dit qu'une feuille de route
interministérielle serait en cours
d'élaboration qu'en est-il si cela est
effectivement en cours quand
pouvons-nous espérer que cette stratégie
nationale tant demandée par de nombreux
acteurs se mettent enfin en place
presque 20 ans après l'interdiction de
l'amiante dans notre pays je vous
remercie merci ma chère collègue la
parole est à Jean-Marie Le Guen
secrétaire des tâches chargée des
relations avec le Parlement vous avez la
parole monsieur ministre merci monsieur
le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice Archambault vous
l'avez dit l'amiante provoque en France
la mort de 1700 personnes chaque année
c'est un des plus grands drames de santé
publique qui est le plus grand drame je
crois de santé publique est connu notre
pays rien que ces 1700 personnes rien
que pour les cancers liés à une activité
professionnelle face à cette situation
grave le gouvernement est déterminé vous
le savez à tout faire pour éviter les
expositions à ce polluant cancérigène
qui est interdit dans notre pays depuis
1997 mais qui est présent encore dans
certains bâtiments des mesures ont
d'ores et déjà été prises pour faciliter
l'extraction de l'amiante dans les
logements existants ainsi la loi de
finances pour 2015 a créé un prêt dédié
aux travaux de traitement de l'amiante
d'ici à 2020 ce prêt qui est délivré par
la Caisse des Dépôts sera mobilisable à
hauteur de 2 milliards d'euros il
permettra vraisemblablement de financer
les travaux dans 40000 logements avec
des taux qui sont inférieurs à ceux du
livret A les organismes de recherche
seront pleinement impliqués dans cet
effort de désamiantage grâce à un plan
d'action sur trois ans mis en place par
le Ministère du Logement et qui vise à
mobiliser les chercheurs pour sécuriser
l'extraction de l'amiante par ailleurs
plusieurs mesures relatives à l'amiante
ont été insérées dans le projet de loi
de modernisation de notre système de
santé que votre assemblée examinera en
première lecture très prochainement tout
d'abord le projet de loi je vous le
rappelle prévoit de renforcer le pouvoir
d'intervention des préfets ils pourront
prendre des mesures contraignantes pour
faire cesser des expositions de fibres
d'amiante ce projet de loi permettra
aussi d'assurer une meilleure
transmission des informations relatives
à l'amiante à l'avenir elles devront
être communiquées non seulement au
préfet mais aussi au ministère chargé de
la santé et du logement de même
contexte renforcera les sanctions
encourues par les propriétaires qui
refuseraient de répondre aux injonctions
en matière de repérage des travaux amiés
cependant au delà des actions de ces
actions sectorielles vous avez eu raison
de souligner que nous devons renforcer
la coordination interministérielle en
matière de lutte de l'amiante les
différentes actions que j'ai évoquées
montrent bien que plusieurs ministères
sont concernés pour ce faire le
ministère de la Santé est en train
d'établir en lien étroit avec les
ministères du développement durable du
travail du logement une feuille de route
vous l'avez souligné un terme
ministériel qui viendra très vite
coordonner les actions de tous les
services compétences
devraient permettre de renforcer
l'information du public sur les risques
liés à la banque et d'aider aussi les
professionnels à agir je pense notamment
aux particuliers au diagnostiqueur et
aux artisans du BTP je vous remercie
merci Monsieur ministre la parole est à
Madame Brigitte Gontier Morin pour le
groupe communiste républicain et citoyen
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre le jour même de la grève des
enseignants contre la réforme des
collèges vous en avez signé le décret
c'est un passage en force choquant oui
il faut une réforme du collège mais si
son objectif est de favoriser la
réussite de tous les élèves de
s'attaquer au mécanisme de l'échec
scolaire pour faire refluer les
inégalités cela ne pourra pas se faire
sans l'engagement et l'adhésion de la
communauté éducative et cette réforme
devrait porter une rupture forte avec
les politiques menées précédemment par
la droite droite et fort opportunément
prétend aujourd'hui des formes d'école
de la République école qu'elle a saccagé
de la suppression de milieu de postes à
la formation des enseignants mais la
réforme du gouvernement appelle aussi la
critique oratrice
mais la réforme du gouvernement appelle
bien la critique car elle repose tout de
même sur une diminution globale des
temps d'enseignement commun obligatoire
au collège vous revendiquez de mieux
préparer tous les collégiens à entrer
dans le monde de demain mais ce monde
caractérisé par des savoirs toujours
plus complexes nécessitent une élévation
du niveau des connaissances pour tous et
donc plus d'écoles vous rétorquer être
personnalisé pratique et
interdisciplinarité pourquoi pas mais
cette interdisciplinarité ne doit pas se
substituer à de fortes acquis
disciplinaires pour tous mais s'appuyer
sur eux et avec quels outils pour les
enseignants le chantier de la formation
continue est toujours en déshérence sans
moyens conséquent quant à la formation
initiale alors que
l'interdisciplinarité est présentée
comme révolutionnant le collège la loi
de refondation ne l'a même pas inscrite
dans des espèces quant à l'autonomie
c'est avant tout celle des
établissements et non des enseignements
qui est renforcé dans un contexte de
baisse des tentations globales horaires
et donc de mise en concurrence la
crainte des enseignants quant à
renforcement des inégalités donc
légitimes parce que tous les élèves ne
rentrent pas au même rythme dans les
apprentissages quand allez-vous accepter
madame la ministre d'envisager à
l'allongement de la scolarité
obligatoire et de véritables pré
recrutements outils essentiels de
transformation de l'école permettant sa
véritable démocratisation la réponse est
à madame la ministre de l'Éducation
nationale de l'Enseignement supérieur et
de la recherche vous avez la parole
madame la ministre
oui merci monsieur le Président Mesdames
et Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice Gontier Morin je vous sais
attaché autant que moi à la réussite
scolaire de tous les enfants en France
donc je veux commencer par vous dire que
je ne comprends pas les oppositions à
cette réforme du collège je ne confonds
pas ce qui relève de ce côté souvent de
la justification des inégalités
scolaires pour mieux permettre de
dégager une élite et ceux qui relèvent
comme vous venez de le faire d'un
certain nombre d'interrogations sur les
modalités pratiques de la mise en oeuvre
de notre réforme c'est pourquoi je veux
vous répondre très clairement sur la
question des disciplines d'abord oui
bien sûr au collège nous avons besoin
d'avoir des professeurs avec des
compétences professionnelles
disciplinaires qui soient capables de
renforcer chaque matière auprès des
élèves c'est la raison pour laquelle
dans la réforme du collège nous ne
portons nullement atteinte aux
disciplines elle ne pas leur temps
horaire baissé oui dans la réforme du
collège nous introduisons de nouveaux
temps dit d'interdisciplinarité ou
plusieurs enseignants seront amenés à
travailler ensemble pour donner plus de
sens à leurs apprentissages aux élèves
et les aider finalement à y entrer
différemment puisque un certain nombre
des élèves vous le voyez bien n'entre
pas suffisamment dans les cours
magistraux théoriques et cloisonnés mais
c'est en interdisciplinarité ils seront
bel et bien assurés par les enseignants
des différentes disciplines chaque
discipline y contribuera le professeur
d'histoire-géo le professeur de français
le professeur de mathématiques sera
amené à apprendre en charge aussi bien
c'est en interdisciplinarité que
l'accompagnement personnalisé c'est la
raison pour laquelle je répète ici que
nul n'a à perdre parmi les enseignants à
cette réforme du collège et qu'au
contraire chacune de ces matières sera
tout simplement mieux approprié mieux
intériorisés par les élèves et c'est
bien l'objectif de cette réforme que les
élèves ne sortent pas du collège sans
avoir compris le sens de ce qu'ils y
apprennent ensuite vous m'avez posé la
question de l'accompagnement des
enseignants pour qu'ils puissent
garantir la bonne mise en oeuvre de
cette réforme oui nous avons besoin de
formation continue indéniablement et
c'est la raison pour laquelle il fallait
que se décret soit publié pourquoi parce
que il fallait dire une fois pour toute
que la réforme se fera pour pouvoir
ensuite discuter avec les organisations
syndicales des modalités d'application
de cette réforme notamment pour ce qui
est de l'accompagnement des
établissements et des équipes en
formation continue qui va pouvoir
commencer très prochainement pour les
cadres de l'éducation nationale pour les
chefs d'établissement puis à l'automne
prochain pour tous les enseignants du
collège afin qu'ils puissent mettre en
oeuvre cette réforme dans les meilleures
conditions possibles merci Madame la
Ministre la parole est à monsieur
Jean-Yves roux pour le groupe socialiste
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
Président mes chers collègues la France
présidera le 30 novembre au 11 décembre
prochain la 21e Conférence des Nations
sur les changements climatiques cette
échéance est cruciale elle doit aboutir
à l'adoption de premier accord universel
et contraignant sur le climat pour
maintenir la température globale en deçà
de 2 degrés Celsius il s'agit en effet
de prendre des mesures qui permettent de
contenir le réchauffement global
195 pays seront impliqués
47000 participants attendus il s'agit là
du plus grand événement diplomatique
jamais organisé tant par l'ampleur qui a
par l'importance de l'enjeu la France à
l'initiative du Président de la
République a d'ailleurs eu le courage de
s'engager et de se porter candidate
mardi dernier le président de la
République François Hollande et la
chancelière allemande Angela Merkel ont
donné à Berlin le coup d'envoi de la
négociation internationale sur le climat
le couple franco-allemand a décidé de
donner un coup d'accélérateur aux
travaux préparatoires de la conférence
climat fin février le président de la
République a lancé l'appel de Manille
afin de sensibiliser gouvernante et
citoyen sur l'urgence de lutter contre
le dérèglement climatique par une
réponse globale portée par tous
aujourd'hui même se termine à Paris au
siège de l'UNESCO le Forum mondial des
entreprises partenaires de la cop21 le
secteur privé a répondu à l'appel du
Secrétaire général de l'ONU et prend un
rôle plus actif dans le processus
mondial de décarbonatation des réseaux
d'entreprises de première ligne ont
décidé d’unir leurs forces et de
convoquer des chefs d'entreprise du
monde entier afin de lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique toutes les
forces doivent être associées afin de
permettre la réussite de la cop21 à la
fin de l'année
nous mesurons cette semaine l'engagement
du gouvernement dans la lutte contre le
dérèglement climatique pourriez-vous
monsieur le ministre nous préciser quels
moyens vous mettez en oeuvre afin de
garantir au maximum le succès de la COP
21 et la réussite des négociations
multilatérales ambitieuse que la France
va présider je vous remercie merci mon
chers collègues la parole est à Monsieur
Laurent Fabius ministre des Affaires
étrangères et du développement
international sur le sénateur merci de
votre question vous avez bien défini
quel est l'objet de cette cop21 il faut
toujours se méfier des épithètes
excessives mais je crois effectivement
que si nous réussissons à convaincre les
186 parties qui devront se prononcer à
l'unanimité
et bien
ce sera vraiment un succès pour le monde
et évidemment aussi un succès pour la
France qui est l'autre de cette
conférence alors il y a quatre objectifs
majeurs le premier
qui est le plus important qui est
jusqu'à présent n'a jamais pu être
atteint c'est d'obtenir je précise les
termes parce qu'ils sont doivent être
appelés un accord universel
différenciée juridiquement contraignant
et j'ajoute un accord durable qui ne
s'arrête pas à 2030 qui est le moment où
normalement les choses devraient
s'arrêter les négociations avancent mais
elles sont très difficiles parce que la
matière elle-même est difficile et
d'autre part mettre d'accord 196 parties
on comprend la difficulté le deuxième
objectif c'est de faire le bilan au
moment aura lieu la conférence de toutes
les contributions nationales que chaque
pays doit délivrer normalement avant la
fin du mois d'octobre nous sommes
à un moment où entre 30 et 40% de la
masse des émissions globales ont fait
l'objet de ces contributions
nous espérons atteindre
90% même plus au moment de la COP de
Paris évidemment ça nous donnera une
indication précise sur les engagements
de chacun des pays ça c'est le deuxième
objectif le troisième c'est tout ce qui
concerne les financements et les
technologies
aucun pays n'est pas principe j'imagine
opposé à cet accord sur le climat mais
beaucoup de pays a commencé par les pays
pauvres ne disent oui c'est très bien
mais où sont les financements où sont
les technologies et il y a eu une série
d'initiative le fond vert qui maintenant
grâce notamment à l'action de
l'Allemagne et la France et dotée de un
peu plus de 10 milliards de dollars il y
a cet objectif en 2020 de 100 milliards
de dollars par an nous avons un gros
travail à faire mais les réunions y
compris celles à laquelle vous avez fait
allusion de Berlin Petersberg il y a
deux jours sont allés en se sentait bien
le quatrième élément vous concerne tous
les autres aussi d'ailleurs c'est
d'associer les parlementaires mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs les régions
les collectivités local les entreprises
du monde entier pour faire que par leur
propre contributions la cop21 soit un
succès et je compte bien sûr sur le
soutien de chacune et chacun de vous
pour cet accord qui sera bénéfique pour
l'ensemble du monde merci Monsieur le
Ministre
la parole est à madame Colette Mello
pour le groupe Union pour un mouvement
populaire monsieur le Président Mesdames
et messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à Madame
Najat Vallaud-Belkacem ministre de
l'Éducation nationale de l'Enseignement
supérieur et de la Recherche madame la
ministre des syndicats d'enseignants
d'irréformistes qui dénonce une
provocation du gouvernement lorsqu'ils
apprennent via la presse que le décret
portant sur la réforme très contestée du
collège à paru hier au Journal officiel
alors que de nombreux enseignants ont
manifesté contre le jour précédent ce
n'est pas banal vous voudrez bien
l'admettre
malgré le grand témoin suscité chez les
enseignants malgré la pétition de 234
parlementaires de la droite et du centre
malgré les propos très sévères
d'intellectuel de tout bord intellectuel
de grande renommée et non pseudo
intellectuel comme vous souhaitez les
appeler vous refusez tout dialogue
vouloir afficher l'idéal politique de la
réduction des inégalités est en soi
fortes estimable mais lorsqu'il est au
détriment de la qualité de l'instruction
c'est inacceptable or c'est bien
l'objectif que vous poursuivez le
nivellement par le bas et en cela vous
faites une terrible erreur d'analyse les
parents des enfants des classes
populaires datant de pas de vous que
vous sabordiez l'élitisme ils attendent
de vous que vous donniez à leurs enfants
les moyens de l'atteindre d'abord par un
enseignement rénové de la lecture qui
permette à chaque élève de savoir lire
comme nous lisons vous et moi mais vous
faites le choix de diminuer le nombre
d'heures d'enseignements de français
vous supprimez le latin et le grec les
classes bilingues les sections
européennes vous proposez dès la
cinquième une deuxième langue vivante et
vous diminuez l'horaire global de
l'enseignement des langues ce qui de ce
fait sera inefficace est-ce comme cela
que vous allez restaurer l'égalité
scolaire les heures d'accompagnement
personnalisées seront prises sur le
temps d'enseignement et ne correspondent
à aucun cas au suivi individuel des
élèves en difficulté est-ce comme cela
que vous permettez à chacun de
progresser en s'adaptant à son niveau
votre credo de la réduction des
inégalités est une vaste hypocrisie vous
êtes en train d'abandonner les enfants
des classes populaires et de dénaturer
profondément notre système éducatif
notamment dans les zones urbaines
sensibles allez-vous enfin Madame la
Ministre écoutez mais surtout entendre
et comprendre ce qui qu'ils viennent
pensent un véritable avenir pour notre
jeunesse et notre pays allez-vous
surseoir à cette réforme du collège et
des programmes ouvrir un vrai dialogue
et une véritable concertation qui serait
la marque d'une recherche sincère d'un
collège qui utilise l'excellence pour le
plus grand nombre merci ma chère
collègue la parole est à madame la
ministre de l'Éducation nationale de
l'Enseignement supérieur et de la
Recherche merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
madame la sénatrice mélo
ça fait plusieurs semaines qu'on entend
parler de nivellement par le bas donc je
vais à mon tour vous donner une
définition de ce qu'est le nivellement
par le bas le nivellement par le bas
c'est quand des familles craignent de
mettre leur enfant dans un collège parce
qu'elles savent que les difficultés
scolaires de quelques enfants dans ce
collège sont si mal prises en charge et
si maltraités que leur enfant risque
d'être tiré vers le bas le nivellement
par le bas c'est quand pendant 10 ans on
assiste sans rien faire les bras
ballants à la dégradation du niveau de
tous les élèves les plus mauvais comme
les meilleurs et que même on l'aggrave
on supprimant des postes d'enseignants
en supprimant la formation des
enseignants qui est quand même a priori
la meilleure garantie de bien
transmettre le savoir aux élèves le
nivellement par le bas c'est quand les
inégalités sociales et le déterminisme
social dans notre école et si
intériorisé que vous avez en effet des
enfants de famille populaire qui
intériorisent totalement le fait que la
réussite s'est pas fait pour eux et qui
s'autocensure en effet dans leur
parcours scolaire dans leur choix et
dans leur perspectives voilà ce qu'est
le nivellement par le bas est-ce que ce
nivellement par le bas est acceptable
non et c'est pour cela que nous
réformons le collège nous leur réformons
pour tirer tout le monde vers le haut
comment on tire tout le monde vers le
haut en renforçant l'acquisition des
fondamentaux par les enfants cela vaudra
pour ceux qui sont en difficulté comme
pour les meilleurs en faisant en sorte
que ce qui doit être acquis par les
enfants à la sortie du collège les
connaissances les compétences et la
culture soient non seulement d'un niveau
élevé mais de même niveau pour tous les
collégiens quelle que soit le territoire
où ils vivent en faisant en sorte que
pendant leur parcours au collège ces
enfants puissent être stimulés encouragé
aider au fond que on cultive chez eux ce
goût du travail de l'effort et du mérite
que vous nous ressassez depuis si
longtemps croyant que tout ça est inné
alors que le travail l'effort et le
mérite ça s'apprend ça se développe ça
se cultive et c'est pour ça que nous
avons besoin de pratique pédagogiques
nouvelles au collège pour le faire c'est
pour ça que nous voulons faire
travailler autrement les enfants dans
ces temps d'interdisciplinarité avec des
enseignants qui leur fassent conduire
des projets dévoiler leur potentiel
parce que chaque enfant a un potentiel
quand je parle d'égalité madame la
sénatrice je parle d'égalité des
possibles pour chaque enfant parce que
je refuse de fermer des portes à des
enfants en fonction du milieu social
auquel ils appartiennent nous serons
d'accord sur tous les bancs alors je
vous remercie de du soutien que vous
apporterez à cette merci madame la
ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Alain jolandet
pour le groupe Union pour mouvement
populaire merci monsieur le Président
Madame la Ministre Les Affaires sociales
et de la santé le régime social des
indépendants le fameux RSI connaît de
grandes difficultés je crois qu'il est
venu le temps d'agir depuis sa création
le recouvrement des cotisations du RSI
auprès des travailleurs indépendants je
le rappelle est effectué par les Urssaf
ce qui n'est pas toujours connu ce
système particulièrement complexe c'est
traduit par de graves défaillances
techniques qui ont affecté un grand
nombre de cotisants difficultés
d'affiliation
erreur dans les appels de cotisation
blocages des mises à jour des dossiers
taxation d'office versement tardif des
prestations etc c'est grave difficulté
ont été relevées d'ailleurs par la Cour
des comptes je le rappelle
je ne reviens pas sur les rappels de
cotisations avec des sommes énormes
considérables effectué parfois de
manière
surprenante je pourrais même dire brutal
parfois auprès des travailleurs
indépendants des efforts ont été
effectués par le RSI c'est absolument
indéniable mais les problèmes ne sont
pas réglés plusieurs mesures me
semblent-ils sont à envisager rapidement
d'abord il est impératif que les
cotisations prévisionnelles des
travailleurs indépendants soient
calculés sur la base du revenu estimé de
l'année en cours et pas de plusieurs
années avant compte tenu de la très
grande variation qu'il y a dans le
revenu des travailleurs indépendants
ensuite même si je n'oublie pas que le
RSI a été créé en 2006 votre
gouvernement madame la ministre a pris
des mesures sur lesquelles je crois il
est nécessaire de revenir le
déplafonnement des cotisations maladie
maternité vieillesse l'instauration
d'une cotisation minimale forfaitaire la
suppression la déduction forfait aire
pour frais professionnels et
l'élargissement de la sujettement de la
suggettissement des dividendes voilà des
mesures qui nous posent beaucoup de
questions une opportunes d'ailleurs en
période de crise économique et qui ont
sensiblement augmenté les charges qui
pèsent actuellement sur les travailleurs
indépendants qui je rappelle assure des
millions d'emplois à notre pays enfin
avec un tel niveau de prélèvement qui
tend à aligner le RSI sur le régime
général avec des prestations qui sont
moindres n'est-il pas venu le temps
d'ailleurs je crois que le premier
ministre avait été ouvert à l'occasion
de questions qui avaient été posée dans
les médias le 31 mars c'est ce qui n'est
pas venu le temps de laisser le choix au
travailleur indépendant qui le
souhaitent de rejoindre ou non le régime
général voilà des questions auxquelles
madame la ministre est très
reconnaissant bien vouloir répondre à la
représentation nationale merci mon cher
collègue la parole est à Madame
marie-sol Touraine ministre des Affaires
sociales de la santé et des droits des
femmes et la parole le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur joliandais c'est
vrai que le régime social des
indépendants a connu et connait encore
de façon moins importante je vais y
revenir a connu de très grandes
difficultés mais vous me permettrez
monsieur le sénateur puisque vous avez
évoqué un rapport de la Cour des comptes
d'être un tout petit peu plus précise
puisque la Cour des comptes parle
d'accident industriels de catastrophes
industrielle en faisant référence à la
réforme qui a été mise en place en 2008
par votre majorité à l'époque et qui ne
sait absolument pas préoccupé de la
manière dont les choses allaient se
décliner et c'est vrai que tout ce que
vous avez évoqué c'est-à-dire des
rappels de cotisations l'incapacité de
joindre des personnes au RSI tout cela a
découlé du dréforme mal pensé mal
préparé et mal mise en oeuvre à partir
de 2008 des mesures pour réparer et
améliorer la situation ont été mises en
place il y a eu une très forte
mobilisation des agents que je veux
saluer du RSI et des
Urssaf et deux de vos collègues ont
l'année dernière produit un rapport qui
montre que les choses se sont
améliorer de manière très significative
même si c'est insuffisant le
gouvernement a pris des mesures il a
baissé les cotisations d'une grande
partie des artisans 70% des artisans ont
vu leur cotisation baisser jusqu'à 400 €
pour ceux qui ont un revenu autour de
20000 euros par an il y a le régime le
régime de la micro-entreprise qui va
permettre des améliorations mais nous
devons aller plus loin et c'est pour
cela que le gouvernement a demandé à
deux députés de parlementaires de
députés Madame butteau et Monsieur
Verdier de faire des propositions de
manière rapprochée pour voir comment
faire évoluer ce régime et mieux
répondre aux attentes des artisans mais
vous me permettrez de conclure vous ne
l'avez pas du tout évoqué je veux le
dire monsieur joliandais je vous
permettrai de conclure en disant que les
difficultés que connaissent certains
artisans ne doivent en aucun cas
légitimer les appels la désaffiliation
de la sécurité sociale qui sont de
manière inconsidérée et irresponsable
poussé par certains parce que la
sécurité sociale c'est la solidarité de
tous vous ne l'avez pas fait je l'ai dit
Monsieur Joyandet mais un certain nombre
de voix s'élèvent pour profiter de cette
situation difficile que connaissent une
minorité d'artisans pour appeler à la
désaffiliation par rapport à la sécurité
sociale c'est le plus mauvais des
services à rendre à la sécurité sociale
et à celle en particulier des artisans
merci Madame la Ministre
la parole est à Madame Maryvonne Blondin
pour le groupe socialiste merci monsieur
le Président Madame la Ministre la
culture n'est pas un luxe c'est une
nécessité disait le prix Nobel de
littérature en 2000 le Premier ministre
vient d'affirmer haut et fort ce qui
était tant attendu par le monde de la
culture la sanctuarisation de son budget
jusqu'à la fin du quinquennat et
l'attachement du Gouvernement à la
culture il s'agit là et il faut le
souligner d'un acte d'engagement tout à
fait exceptionnel de confiance et de
reconnaissance pour ce secteur fragilisé
en cette période difficile d'efforts
collectifs pour redresser l'économie de
notre pays et fort ok le budget de la
culture a pris sa part en faisant porter
la baisse de ces crédits essentiellement
sur les grands opérateurs de l'État
plutôt que sur le secteur de la création
production et diffusion culturelle et
l'éducation artistique favoriser le
développement de la création des
pratiques culturelles lutter contre les
inégalités permettre à tous d'accéder à
la culture c'est ce qui constitue l'ADN
de la gauche d'ailleurs l'article 27 de
la Déclaration universelle des droits de
l'homme de l'UNESCO ne dit pas autre
chose en érigeant les droits culturels
comme droit fondamentaux je me réjouis
donc de cette nouvelle étape qui
réaffirme la place essentielle de la
culture dans notre société et son apport
dans le lien social et l'économie de nos
territoires néanmoins force et de
constater que ce secteur a fait l'objet
de coupe sombre dans les derniers
budgets des collectivités alors que
celle-ci en sont certes les principaux
financeurs mais aussi les principaux
bénéficiaires c'est pourquoi je me
félicite madame la ministre que vous
ayez proposé un pacte qui maintiendra
les crédits de l'État dans les
territoires pour les trois prochaines
années à condition que les collectivités
acceptent elles aussi de stabiliser leur
financement culturel hier à Matignon
plus d'une trentaine d'éluses de droite
comme de gauche qui tous croient en la
culture ont signé des pactes culturels
ma question madame la ministre quels
sont les moyens que vous allez mettre en
oeuvre d'une part pour permettre la
généralisation et pérennisation de ces
politiques culturelles conjointe état
collectivités et d'autre part pour
assurer une progression durable des
moyens de votre ministère je vous
remercie merci ma chère collègue la
parole est à Madame Fleur Pellerin
ministre de la Culture et de la
Communication merci monsieur le
président madame la sénatrice Blondin
vous l'avez dit des choix courageux ont
été faits en 2012 pour redresser nos
comptes publics la culture y a pris une
part importante mais jamais les
marqueurs auxquels nous sommes attachés
n'ont été abîmés la création la
diffusion culturelle l'éducation
artistique et culturelle ont été
protégées dans tous les budgets depuis
2012 pour autant est-ce suffisant bien
sûr que non et je comprends que le monde
de la culture soit impatient et en
manifeste les signes madame la sénatrice
nous ouvrons actuellement une page
nouvelle de ce quinquennat en matière
culturelle et ce n'est pas qu'une
question budgétaire et d'ailleurs je
rappelle qu'un budget ce n'est jamais
qu'un moyen au service d'un projet et
qu'un arbitrage budgétaire c'est une
décision sur la base d'un projet c'est
une offensive culturelle globale que je
souhaite ouvrir désormais offensive
culturel quand je signe à travers toute
la France des pactes culturels qui
engagent vous l'avez dit état pour trois
ans aux côtés des villes et des
agglomérations qui font le choix de
préserver le budget de la culture hier
35 villes ont signé un pacte avec l'État
en présence du Premier ministre Manuel
Valls et avant l'été une soixantaine
auront répondu à cet appel cette
démarche cette démarche partenariale il
faut l'amplifier il faut l'approfondir
compte tenu de la réforme territoriale
en cours offensive culturel aussi en
écoutant ce qui remonte des territoires
par exemple sur les conservatoires de
musique et bien j'ai décidé de réengager
l'état auprès des conservatoires pour en
faire un vrai instrument de
démocratisation il faut faire évoluer
les pratiques pédagogiques il faut
mettre l'accent sur les cours collectifs
il faut faire rentrer dans les
conservatoires de nouvelles esthétiques
et les ouvrir aussi pourquoi pas aux
adultes offensifs culturel encore quand
nous sécurisons et nous pérennisons le
statut des intermittents dans la loi de
modernisation du dialogue social porté
par François epsonen sans les
intermittents pas de singularité
culturelle française pas de culture au
sens où nous l'entendons offensive
culturel toujours avec courant juin la
présentation en conseil des ministres
d'un projet de loi ambitieux en faveur
de la liberté de création de
l'architecture et du patrimoine un
projet de loi qui rappellera
l'attachement de la nation à la création
artistique un projet de loi bâti autour
d'un triptyque liberté protection et
partage madame la sénatrice vous citiez
Gao shinja en ouverture de votre
question c'est vrai la culture n'est pas
un luxe c'est une nécessité et les
budgets de la culture seront en hausse
en 2016 comme en 2017 il soutiendront
cette offensive culturel à laquelle je
vous invite à participer merci madame la
ministre
nous en avons fini avec les questions
d'actualité au Gouvernement je vais
suspendre la séance elle sera reprise à
16h15 pour la discussion de la
proposition de loi tendante à modifier
le régime applicable à Paris en matière
de pouvoir de police la séance est
suspendue
voilà donc pour cette séance des
questions d'actualité au Gouvernement
marqué par 5 questions sur 10 sur la
réforme du collège je vous retrouve tout
de suite pour refaire ensemble la séance
avec nos invités
bonjour à tous merci de nous rejoindre
en direct du Sénat après la séance des
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
que vous avez pu suivre en direct sur
notre antenne cet après-midi nous allons
revenir sur ces différents sujets
d'actualité avec nos deux invités et nos
deux premiers invités qui vont nous
rejoindre dans quelques instants Didier
Guillaume le président du groupe
socialiste au Sénat et Jean-Pierre
Raffarin le président de la commission
des affaires étrangères du Sénat une
séance des questions d'actualité marquée
cet après-midi par cinq questions sur
dix sur la réforme du collège des
questions auxquelles Najat
Vallaud-Belkacem a répondu la ministre
de l'Éducation a annulé cet après-midi
un déplacement pour venir répondre aux
interrogations des sénateurs cet
après-midi je vous propose d'écouter la
ministre de l'Éducation avant de
recevoir donc nos deux premiers invités
un collège de 500 élèves prenez un
collège de 500 élèves aujourd'hui il n'a
que 10 heures de dotation globale pour
faire du travail en petits groupes grâce
à la réforme en 2016 il en aura 60
heures ça veut dire qu'il aura plus de
moyens pour faire travailler les élèves
en petits groupes ça veut dire qu'on les
met en meilleure condition de réussite
expliquez-moi en quoi mettre en
meilleure condition de réussite le plus
grand nombre va nuire à ceux qui
aujourd'hui sont dans la réussite au
contraire on le dit souvent plus que le
niveau de l'eau s'élève et plus tous les
bateaux monte et bien cette réforme elle
va dans l'intérêt aussi bien des élèves
en difficulté que des élèves qui sont en
réussite voilà Najat Vallaud-Belkacem
tout à l'heure dans l'hémicycle du Sénat
elle répondait à une des nombreuses
questions autour de la réforme du
collège on va y revenir dans quelques
instants avec nos deux invités d'abord
Jean-Pierre Raffin le président de la
commission des affaires étrangères du
Sénat qui s'installe sur ce plateau
bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
en attendant Didier Guillaume le
président du groupe socialiste qui va
vous rejoindre sur ce plateau une
question sur la site antique de Palmyre
qui est tombée aux mains de l'État
islamique qu'il est dans d'abord votre
réaction Jean-Pierre Raffarin c'est une
grande tristesse c'est une grande
inquiétude et j'approuve tout à fait
l'initiative que vient de prendre la
secrétaire général de l'UNESCO pour
mobiliser les forces internationales
pour qu'on résiste à cette situation
très préoccupante est-ce que ça ne
demande pas quand même les limites de
l'intervention américaine et occidentale
autour de la Syrie autour de l'État
islamique est-ce qu'il faut revoir la
stratégie je pense que la question est
posée il est difficile aujourd'hui
d'être dans la position qui était celle
du gouvernement français quand on nous
disait Nini ni daesh ni Bachar
aujourd'hui il est clair que daesh est
un adversaire majeur sur ce sujet et on
ne peut pas laisser détruire la palmier
Raffarin il y a eu tout à l'heure au
sein d'une conférence de presse autour
du projet loi renseignement qui va être
débattu ici au Sénat à partir du 2 juin
je sais pas si ils avaient eu le temps
de lire le monde de ce soir mais le
monde dévoile l'acquisition d'imsi
catcher je sais pas si je prononce bien
parce que je suis pas très spécialiste
de la question sont des dispositifs
d'écoute illégaux qui aurait été achetés
par les services de douane en France
est-ce que d'une part en tant que
président la commission des affaires
étrangères vous souhaitez lancer une
enquête sur ces achats
c'est une technique que le projet de loi
autorise ou certaines circonstances avec
des contrôles donc il ne s'agit pas de
choses qui soient à rejeter dans son
ensemble ce qu'il faut bien antérieur
mais à l'actuel projet de loi qui
discutait par le Parlement de ce projet
de loi aujourd'hui c'est de pouvoir
légaliser un certain nombre de
techniques qui pouvaient être dans ces
situations majeures et d'urgence
utiliser ce projet de loi a été amélioré
par le Sénat nous avons renforcé et nous
renforcerons encore en sciences pénière
mais ce matin commission des lois en
commission des affaires étrangères nous
avons développé des propositions pour
protéger l'aspect liberté mais de ce
point de vue là les SMIC actions vous
savez c'est d'avoir les données de
connexion non pas le contenu des
conversations mais là où un terroriste
est à un moment isolé on peut savoir
avec qui il est en contact donc ce sont
des mesures très utiles dans la lutte
contre le terrorisme vous avez
l'impression que que le texte tel qui va
être un monde mais à demander par le
Sénat il y a 145 amendements qui ont été
déposés va garantir contre un risque
d'écoute de surveillance d'ampleur il y
a encore des inquiétudes dans le pays il
y a des inquiétudes mais voilà on va
voter ce texte qui prouve bien qu'on est
objectif nous dans l'opposition et quand
on dit que la réforme du collège est
mauvaise et le texte est bon